when i did my book reasons to vote for
democrats a comprehensive guide number
one best-selling blank book
about four years ago still selling like
hotcakes by the way so thank you to
everyone who's giving the gift of
knowledge to themselves and their
friends
when i did that book
some people gave me the title king of
the trolls
okay
and vanity fair
called me a dapper lib triggering troll
and they they thought that this blank
book was a really good troll and i agree
it was fun enjoyed it
i may need to relinquish my crown
i may need to hand my crown to a
colleague of mine that would be mr matt
walsh
who wanted to go speak at a loudoun
county school board meeting this is a
school board meeting in virginia
but he doesn't live in virginia it's not
a big deal you can go to public school
board meetings except that when the
school board found out he was going to
go they had a requirement that you had
to be a virginia resident so what does
matt do is he deterred no he just rents
an apartment
in virginia then he goes there and he
shows up last night and they pulled a
bunch of other shenanigans to try to
keep him out limit what he could say not
stream the speech
but there was a big rally outside
and matt gets up there matt who
you know i guess he's lived in virginia
for a few days now
i'm not sure how much longer he's going
to live in virginia
he has really only lived in tennessee
for some months now and we're actually
kind of new to the south in general
but matt gets up on the back of a pickup
truck to give a speech
and the people there chant all the
parents in loudoun county
welcome home matt
thank you
maybe it's not even matt who gets king
of the trolls maybe it is the concerned
parents of loudoun county because they
they got it they went along with it uh
matt you know matt got to go say his
piece i'm glad he did obviously the i
think the the message was clear who
cares what anyone said in the room the
fact that there was a major rally
outside of the school board meeting
frankly
that's all you need to know about the
sending the message to the school board
but
to to me what's more interesting than
the critical race theory curriculum or
the kind of radicalism in the schools or
what was more interesting even than matt
going and showing up there
are those parents
who are outside who are cheering on
a
recent
a recent resident of tennessee who
got a place in in virginia for a couple
of days they say welcome home matt and
they're playing along what it shows me
is
politics is no longer local in this
country you know in my wayward youth i
was not particularly interested in my
physical fitness okay it's just
something that i kind of ignored i never
really cared about then i had a kid
and my kid
he he's crawling around everywhere he's
getting bigger and bigger every day i
got to make sure i can lift him up it's
very important to make sure that you are
fit whether you're a young parent
whether you're just a young person in
general whether you just want to feel
good work out your stress get back to
feeling great i would strongly recommend
planet fitness join the judgment free
zone today
for just 10 bucks a month get tons of
cardio and strength equipment in those
clean wonderful clubs
with free fitness training plenty of
room to move you can go at your own pace
get back to a routine that works for you
all for just 10
dollars a month ten bucks a month there
are coffee drinks that cost more than
ten dollars go right now check out the
crowd meter in the free pf app for the
best time to visit don't wait join any
of the two thousand plus locations today
in club online or on the app see the
club for details there was an old old
expression tip o'neill former democrat
speaker of the house used to say all
politics is local and that was common
sense in america for a very long time i
don't think that is the case any longer
occasionally i'll go to a small town i
mean i travel all over the country and
when i'm in a small town i don't always
even see a local paper anymore but
sometimes they'll still have a local
paper and i find it so refreshing it
reminds me of what the country used to
be like 20 years ago not that long ago
and it's got the the local head of the
community and he's writing about the
local issues and we just don't see that
a lot anymore increasingly the issues
that preoccupy our time even in small
town america are national issues you see
this in latin county it's not just that
there's some weird creepy thing going on
in the schools there that's particular
to loudoun county it's that this creepy
thing is going on in the schools all
over the country and that would be the
critical race theory curriculum that
would be the radical gender curriculum
and so you can have a national
conservative media figure like matt
walsh come in there and he's welcomed
like a hometown hero
this is partially i think technological
because you've you've got the
proliferation of the internet and ways
to connect to people now who might be on
the other side of the country or on the
other side of the world
but also you've got a breakdown of the
local community
so as our
local governments local voluntary
associations the lions club and and
whatever as the local churches even as
the family breaks down people move away
people have
other unusual sorts of family
arrangements people are living on their
own more as that happens it's not that
we're no longer going to have community
we're just going to have different kinds
of community so now
the these parents in loudoun county have
much more in common with matt walsh than
they do with any member of their school
board i'm so glad you like that clip
ring the bell
ring it ring the bell subscribe that way
you won't miss out on the videos also
head on over if you wouldn't mind to
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play wherever you get your podcasts type
in
michaelano show subscribe
and i will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you